I'm its head and you're the legs there
will be times when the legs are more
important than the head so if I die
someone else will take over what's
important is the survival of the whole
not the individual together we are the
spider hello.log up to Hunter hunter 101
series that breaks down everyone and
everything in the Hunter hunter world
and today we are going to be zeroing in
on one of the most infamous groups in
the series The Phantom troupe the
Phantom troupe is a collective of 13
extraordinarily skilled men users who
warrant a Class A bounty and were first
introduced into the series during the
york-new arc although they were
interested by qurupeco way way way back
in the very second chapter of the manga
the troupe originates from a junkyard
civilization known as meteo City a
location that does not appear on any map
nor do its citizens have any official
record it acts primarily as a dumping
ground for other nations wishing to get
rid of garbage or even people estimate
to be at least 500 years old with the
motto of will accept anything you leave
here but don't ever take anything away
from us and it would be here that a
young crawler Lucifer would form the
Phantom troupe and take a select group
of at least six individuals out of meteo
city to commence a life of crime
throughout the world the confirmed
founding members of the trip were
Valjean
Payton Porter Franklin Bordeaux Michiko
mechina Nobunaga's Ozma PACU Noda as
well as Crowley's for himself of course
and it also has been heavily implied
that Fink's Magog and shall knock were
amongst this original group although the
last two are not confirmed
however commencing their operations the
trip would go on to recruit four other
members and adopts the moniker of spider
the reason for which directly correlates
to the structure of the troop members as
the 13 of them represent the 12 legs and
one hit of a spider and yes I know that
spiders don't have 12 legs but you know
you try telling that to crows see how
well that works out for you this
metaphor does however nicely explain the
hierarchy of the group with all 12 legs
being considered equal mostly orders of
the head are to be considered the utmost
priority to this end each member of the
troupe receives a tattoo of spider
designating their affiliation and each
sporting a number between 1 to 12 now
these numbers are assigned or whether or
not there are any greater meaning to
them is currently unknown so for example
they don't represent the order in which
people join the troop because one of the
founding members of again is branded
with number 11 nor do they indicate the
strength of that particular troop member
because once again wolf again as the
physically strongest member
is still branded with 11 regardless the
only real ranking that matters is
whoever holds the position of head the
head is the only member of the group who
has the authority to call a mandatory
troop assembly and they are also the
only individual capable of punishing
current members while adding new members
so with this structure in mind the
Phantom troop generally operate in the
realm of thievery stealing very rare
items and using them to acquire vast
amounts of wealth however this
description doesn't quite do justice to
the more our brutal ends that the fandom
troupe will resort to in order to
complete their goals the best example of
this is probably when they conducted a
systematic genocide of the kurta clan to
the sole purposes of harvesting the
clans famed scarlet eyes which had been
known to sell from anywhere between 900
million to 2 billion Jennie and the
possession of them are a symbol of
status amongst extraordinary wealthy
monarchs and businessman and due to the
skill set of the Phantom troop genocide
is a fairly achievable task although
that is not to say that troop members
cannot be defeated because that is far
from the truth in fact by the time they
were introduced in the series two of
their members had already been defeated
with the number 8 spider having been
killed by silver zoldak who would go on
to engage in combat with chrono as well
and the previous number 4 spider having
been defeated by hosaka mora who went on
to take number 4 spot for himself
speaking of new members after the group
left meteo City they acquired some new
blood in the form of Manila Novato P and
Shizuku Murasaki the latter of which was
recruited to replace the number 8 spot
and this group now forms the makeup of
the Phantom troop as they were
introduced to us during the york new
city arc in which they acted as the
primary antagonist seeking to steal an
incredible whole of merchandise being
sold off in an underground mafia auction
and during this effort it was revealed
that the Phantom troupe is a bit more
structurally diverse with members being
assigned to certain sectors of
operations depending on their particular
abilities for example there was a
commando team who were responsible for
front-line combat missions and at this
time it consisted of Nobunaga and Vogon
to individuals whose abilities are
highly adept and rendering people dead
then there was also an intelligence
branch that consisted of shall knock and
Paco Noda as well as the cleanup squad
which consists solely of Shizuku and
this strategy was incredibly effective
for quite some time
although the troops plans were almost
single-handedly foiled by Korra pika the
last surviving member of the Kota clan
who had made it his mission in life to
hunt down the Phantom chirp and who had
the skated his nan abilities
specifically to dealing with them this
conflict began when Korra pika was able
to abduct a folk in using his chain jail
technique which is an incredible feat
because a state
before oofah gain was physically the
strongest member of the troupe and had
previously single-handedly dispatched a
group of incredibly powerful men uses
known as the shadow beasts in any case
you get the idea of again was strong as
hell and yet pretty much helpless
against career pick ax to the point
where he would end up being killed by
kerekes judgement chain furthermore by
the end of the arc park uno de would
also go on to lose her life due to the
same technique and krola would be
rendered unable to use nen or even
contacts the troupe once again thanks to
a very specifically Cajun judgment chain
and to add insult to injury he Sokka
also ended up leaving the troupe after
it became clear that his desired to
fight crow lo would go unfulfilled and
so the troupe suffered a fairly
overwhelming defeat during the orc new
city arc however they would end up
banding together to remove Korra Pickers
ability from crow lo although the
spiders would spend a fair amount of
time hitless so much so that an interim
leader would need to be chosen and this
event occurred during the Chimera ant
arc when a former squadron leader named
Zaza decided to build a hive in meteor
city and wreak havoc upon its residents
as a result in a red display
philanthropy the phantom troupe returned
to the place when most of them
originated and exterminated the chimera
ants resulting in Phaeton becoming the
interim leader of the group as he was
the one to kill Zaza and it is here that
we are going to put up the old spoiler
warning for those of you who have only
seen the anime and have not delved into
the manga look there's no guarantee that
the manga is ever going to get an under
anime adaptation but if you are still
absolutely intent on not knowing what
has happened then please do skip to this
time but for the rest of you let us
continue eventually an exorcist was
acquired for krolow and he returned to
the position of head amongst the trip
and this Exorcist was retrieved by
Hisoka actually due to his strong lost
in regards to fighting crow though the
match which eventually occurred in
Heaven's Arena resulting in Crowley's
victory and seemingly
he saw his death however this was about
two clever ruse from the magician whose
postmortem then revived him and he
proceeded to kill both [ __ ] and Kota
P and currently the Phantom troupe are
aboard the black whale one bound for the
Dark Continent with the goal of stealing
treasures from the cocoon Kingdom as
well as extracting revenge against
ahsoka and very notably they have also
added two new members to their ranks one
of which is color - zoldak who took the
number-4 spot after Hisoka left as well
as his older brother illumise old ik we
adopted the number 11 spot after having
been hired by Hisoka to join the troupe
in order to attempt to kill him some
more fun facts about the phantom troupe
with so many strong personalities
amongst the troupe disputes are
inevitable
however there is a blanket rule that no
sir
fights are permitted which means that
disputes which cannot be resolved
through discussion are solved through
the system of a coin flip in the
non-canon film Hunter hunter phantom
urge an original character named OMA
kaga was introduced who was said to be
the former number four of the troop boom
he soccer replaced however I would once
again like to point out that this is not
canon and the true original number four
spot remains unknown rather
interestingly all known holders of the
number four ranked within the Phantom
troop have proven themselves to be
either treacherous possessed hidden
agendas or both and this even extends to
the aforementioned non-canon or macaca
the symbol of the twelve legged spider
as well known in the hunt underworld but
some people even going so far as to pass
themselves off as a member of the
phantom troupe however what immediately
gives them away is the knowledge they
don't possess which is that all of the
spider tattoos contain a number during
the orc new city arc our protagonist
gone was captured by the troupe and
managed to impress Nobunaga's so much
that he even invited gone to join the
troupe a proposition that gone
immediately refused however quite
notably this was not within Nobunaga's
right to do and it was later clarified
that a nomination process would have had
to occur and the crawler most likely
would never sign on to the idea of Gahan
becoming a spider even if he wanted to
despite the troop being world-famous for
Class A bounties somehow the knowledge
of crawler being its leader is not
widespread and he has been something of
an enigma to the world prior to his
actions in york-new City anyway whilst
numbers at the spiders seem to have
little to no significance there is one
solid ranking amongst the troupe which
is in regards to the wonderful art of
armwrestling quite notably this contest
is of pure strength and performed
without engaging in any form of nirn use
but it gives us a good general idea of
who amongst the group is physically
strongest with a couple of interesting
surprises as well such as machi sitting
crazily there just above Carlo at number
six
several of the Phantom troupe members
are based quite blatantly on iconic
horror characters for example Franklin
is rather obviously paying homage to
Frankenstein's monster while Spinola
knov takes on the guise of a mummy and
caught topi bears resemblance to a
classical Japanese ghost the most famous
of which we would know is Sadako from
the ring franchise in fact you know what
you could even lumpy soccer and on this
trend given that he chooses to adorn
himself as s some sort of terrifying
clown thing and finally a truly useless
fact despite the fact that krola
originally ordered the Phantom troupe to
meet up in York New City on August 30th
they would in fact meet up on August
31st
and I honestly feel like that truly is
one of the most useless things I have
ever said in any video but that pretty
much does it for the Phantom troupe if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the new
world review patreon because the support
of all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
and any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with who
what or where you'd like to see featured
on the next hunt anta 101
[Music]
[Music]